[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today Justin is
in Salt Lake hi Justin welcome to the
Ramsey
Show how's it going guys thank you guys
for taking my call so I am on H baby
step number two of paying off my debt
and I have about $338,000 worth of debt
and I'm 21
so call you guys and see if I can get
some advice on what kind of debt have
you got
situation uh so I got got a p VI phone
bill of
$1,900 I got a credit card debt for $700
I got a personal loan out for, 1500 I
got two possessions one for 5,000 one
for 10,000 I got a current car loan for
12,000 and I ow my uh girlfriend's
Grandma $7,000 you owe your girlfriend's
dad grandma grandma $7,000
yeah she helped me uh get down pay on my
new vehicle because my old one blew a
motor on it and I am employed by her so
you're employed by vehicle what do you
do for your girlfriend's
grandmother uh so they do they on a
audio visual company so we uh run the
equipment in Park City Utah for hotel
like St arkinson logs and a couple other
places we do weddings and business
meetings okay so I just go in and
how have you managed to get two cars
repoed in your 21 years
old uh so when I had 18 I bought my
first got my first auto loan out and it
was for uh 10,000 Au lease and I made a
bad mistake on that one and the vehicle
had issues and the motor went out and I
said okay guys I'm not paying on this
anymore so I let them repossess it so
that was a voluntary repo and then the
$10,000 one was I got intimidate fa
accident and remaining balance on the
loan is uh what my insurance wouldn't
cover because you didn't have enough
coverage that is correct okay well when
I went broke at 28 years old Justin and
lost everything I had a ba two babies
and a marriage Hanging On by a thread I
made the decision I was going to do a
detailed analysis of how stupid I had
been so that I didn't do it
again you seem to be repeating
you seem to be repeating this
pattern like cars are killing
you oh I've been through 18 cars in the
last four years
so yeah cars are killing you yeah yeah
they are yeah okay what do you
make uh I make about
$37,000 Ann every year okay are you
gotting side
jobs uh no I've been picking up a lot of
overtime at this
my current job I've been working 80s 100
100 hour weeks and you're making 37,000
doing that yeah that's just my base
without my over my overtime my overtime
wages are about $3300 every two weeks
okay all right so another 36,000 you're
doubling your
income that is that would make sense if
you're working 80 hours instead of 40
okay so that'd be logical okay so um
good all right so you're making like 70
as long as you can continue to get the
OT and if you can't the OT pick up
something else right yep okay that's
good we had a slow season we had a slow
season about November so I got a second
job lined up okay are you paying
payments on the $1900 old foone
Bill uh yes I actually uh I'm paying
$300 a month until I get enough to wipe
that one out and I know my credit card
lost payment is going to be coming out
next week on Thursday so I'll be losing
that $600 credit card Deb okay the two
repos will settle with you for pennies
on the dollar lump some and so if you
have a $10,000 repo deficit the big one
you probably could offer them $3,000
cash and they'll take it you're going to
have to argue with them and act like
you're broke and Carry On and whine and
I can't pay it and this is all I can do
and otherwise I'm going to have to file
bankruptcy and you're going to have to
threaten them and all this stuff but you
flop around on the floor and foam at the
mouth a little bit and then they'll you
can eventually get them to settle for
about three
grand
okay and the same thing on the 5,000 you
ought to be able to do that for about
1,500
bucks get it in writing offer them a
lump sum nothing no payments no payment
plans I can't put you on a payment plan
I don't have room to have another
payment plan I've already got a car
payment that's why this got repoed
because I'm a broke guy so but broke
guy's 21 years old and I want to settle
this I can give you $3,000 cash or I can
give you nothing and you can get nothing
which do you want do you want nothing I
can do nothing I can hang up the phone
and you'll get nothing what is it you
want and this is how you have to talk to
them because they're brain
damaged all right you got to really lean
in dude you got to really lean in and
then get it in writing from them before
you send them any money and do not allow
them to have electronic access to your
checking account because they will take
everything in your account not what you
agreed to because they
lie okay okay it's an industry of
scum and so you have to treat it like
you're dealing with pure evil even
though you're the one that didn't pay
your bill but you still have to go treat
them like you're handling an alligator
okay okay and uh so get it in writing No
Electronic access to your checking
account then you can give them a
one-time prepaid debit card number put
the put the amount on there or you can
wire it to them or you can do whatever
but no they do not give them where you
work don't give them your social
security number don't give them your
current address don't give them anything
except
$3,000 and if you want that I'll give it
to you but if you don't I'm gonna let
you talk to a dial tone I got another
repo I can call and talk
to okay and this is how you have to
negotiate hard hard ball and then get
these things out of your life and then
quit borrowing money on
cars yeah that's my uh that's my not
yeah never do it again okay yeah no 21
and you're already a two-time loser
don't do this
anymore no learn the
lesson yeah what's worse on my situation
my car insurance is like $700 a month on
top of my car payment so that's why you
tickets uh close Okay 91 okay I think we
got to stop you from driving around man
I I think you don't need cars at all
goodness gracious just nothing in your
life about cars has turned out good you
even got them blown from your girl
friend's grandmother who's your employer
this sounds like four guns pointed at
your face to me that's a country
girlfriend you lose the job you lose the
car everything could go wrong if granny
gets pissed here this is bad oh man
clean this up man get it out of your
life get this stuff go make a bunch of
money clean these debts up as soon don't
do anything else I don't want to hear
about you going out to eat and you
certainly don't need to see happy hour
there's nothing to be happy about you
need to get this mess cleaned up